Hello I’m eerily Andrew Creepton
and you’re fiendishly watching Ghostly Weekly
Halloween is nigh,
and that means carving faces into produce,
stuffing pets into costumes,
and playing Russian Roulette with Type-II
diabetes
by ingesting industrial-strength amounts of
candy.
Perhaps you leave out bowls of sweets for
neighborhood trick-or-treaters.
I don’t, because I believe in practical
gifts.
And a bottle of ibuprofen for you!
Ever wonder what goes into the sugar that
goes into your coffee?
That sugar you’re buying costs more because
of sugar cronyism.
And a bunch of sugar barons are getting rich
off of us suckers.
Why?
Big Sugar.
That’s not just my drag queen name,
it’s a reference to the special interests
who get rich off government protection.
The sugar industry is a big cartel that meters
out fun white powder.
It's like cocaine only it makes you fat, and
it’s legal and much less fun at parties.
It’s indicative of a broader issue in our
country of crony capitalism.
These tiny little green dots are where we
grow sugar cane.
That’s because America’s climate is wonderfully,
spectacularly suited
to not grow sugar cane.
Sugar magnates compensate for their crummy
business model
through subsidized loans and laws that protect
them from competition,
inflating the price of sugar and ensuring
a sweet profit…
I SAID NO PUNS.
We run our sugar industry with Soviet-style
central planning,
which, granted, has historically been a great
way to mass produce low-quality automobiles
and starvation.
Let’s say there’s a surplus of sugar,
the government, has to buy the extra sugar
and resell it -- at a loss.
Or if the market price drops below a certain
level,
the USDA has to activate sugar-for-ethanol
program to find the sugar industry new buyers.
Not many other industries get that kind of
treatment.
If nobody wants to buy my jokes I don’t
get to sell them to ethanol plants --
I have to give them for free to Jimmy Fallon.
[Rimshot]
When you add in the onerous tariffs the government
imposes on foreign sugar,
we're stuck with expensive American sugar,
which is also one of my drag names.
Sugar costs are why Chicago is no longer the
candy capital of the world,
why Oreo and York Peppermint Patty and Hershey's
have moved out of the country,
and why Willy Wonka is dead.
A report from the International Trade Administration
found that nearly three jobs in candy making
were lost
for every one sugar-growing job protected.
Unnecessary handouts are indicative of a broader
issue in our economy.
Sugar companies have a virtual monopoly on
production
but they don’t have a monopoly on handouts.
Here’s a list of other industries that receive
unnecessary handouts.
Slop around a few billion dollars here, and
a few billion dollars there,
and pretty soon we’re robbing Americans
and jacking up the National Debt.
Democrats and Republicans and libertarians
and Libertarians and Methodists
and my friend Steve,
should all come together to stop this sugary
graft.
America’s sugar program is an unwieldy mechanism
designed to enrich a few plutocratic Sugar
Babies.
I said no puns, I'm not gonna do one!